[Musique]
bonjour nouveau débat sur tv 78
également sur radio sensations dans le
cadre de ce premier tour des élections
municipales débat aujourd'hui consacré à
la ville de guyancourt cinq listes sont
déclarés au 9 février à la liste
guyancourt pour tous porté par françois
morton ensemble agissons pour guyancourt
porté par rodolphe baril le nouvel élan
à guyancourt portait pas grégory pape
décidons ensemble pour guyancourt
apporté par olivier paréja et puis
également une liste d'union des
démocrates musulmans français porté par
ma bella est des qte les cinq invités
cinq représentants de ces listes sont en
plateau bonsoir à tous les cinq
ils ont su merci d'avoir répondu à cette
invitation au cours de ce débat le temps
de parole sera chronométrée afin de
s'assurer au mieux de l'égalité du temps
de parole entre chacun d'entre vous nous
allons débuter avec une première
question est la même pour tous vous
aurez une minute à peu près pour pour y
répondre
enfin de vous laisser du temps pour les
thématiques à suivre pourquoi vous
présentez pour ce scrutin est pourquoi
les électeurs devraient vous faire
confiance nous allons débuter partira
comme l'indiqué le tirage au sort avec
vous olivier paréja pardon vous avez été
élus en 2014 avec la liste majoritaire
vous avez pris vos distances depuis vous
faisiez aussi partie d'europe écologie
les verts
voilà pour les quelques précisions
d'introduction pourquoi vous présentez
cette fois ci en tant que tête de liste
et pourquoi les électeurs doit vous
faire confiance alors la démarche
absolument pas personnel c'est à dire
que on a créé un collectif depuis
maintenant près d'un an et en faisant
des ateliers dans la rue en faisant des
ateliers participatifs
on est arrivé globalement à construire
un programme est ensuite construire une
liste pour porter ce programme donc
c'est vraiment une démarche très
participative que on a voulu mettre en
place et pour porter en particulier
l'urgence écologique c'est-à-dire que
les communes sont vraiment le niveau où
on peut faire beaucoup de choses pour le
climat et on pourrait aller beaucoup
plus loin que ce qui ne se fait
aujourd'hui
et c'est en plus ce cette urgence là
qu'on veut porter il ya bien ce n'est
entendu l'urgence aussi sociale et la
solidarité qu'il faut porter et donc
c'est pour porter toutes ces valeurs que
ce collectif s'est créé et qui
finalement m'a désigné comme tête de
liste mais plus comme porte parole que
que vraiment autre chose
françois morton maire sortant élu en
2014 étiez sur la liste de françois de
ligne à vendre verte il revêtir
l'écharpé tricolore en 2019 l'année
dernière même question pour vue
absolument
donc j'ai répondu présent à l'appel de
français de liens 2014 pour m'engager
localement pour la ville de guyancourt
et hors jeu n'était pas prédestiné à
devenir mère c'est une réalité
maintenant je le suis je le suis avec
beaucoup d enthousiasme j'ai eu
j'ai le grand plaisir et j'ai eu le
grand plaisir cette semaine de présenter
mes trente quatre colistiers mardi
dernier et donc c'est bien une équipe
que je représente aussi aujourd'hui une
équipe à l'image de la ville avec un
programme je me suis permis de l'amener
parce que il est présent il a été
distribué à alençon d'aiguillon courtois
et durant le mois de janvier il est issu
d'un travail de co-construction avec les
habitants notamment au travers
d'ateliers qui ont eu lieu au mois de
novembre
et je suis assez fier effectivement de
pouvoir présenter ce programme qui est
un programme complet structuré et
cohérent et réalisa rodolphe barrez vous
vous revendiquez sans parti en tout cas
plutôt tendance centriste
vous aviez quitté la politique en 2014
avant ça vous étiez adjoint voisins le
bretonneux
c'est exact écoutez j'ai l'honneur de
conduire la liste le apg qui étaient
ensemble agissons pour guyancourt qui
est une liste indépendante d'intérêt
local ouverte à toutes les sensibilités
politiques dans quelle soit écologiste
de gauche centristes de droite ce projet
j'y travaille depuis près de trois ans
quel point que ce que je participe à
tous les conseils enfin jeu j'assiste à
tous les conseils municipaux depuis
trois ans c'est également le fruit d'une
longue réflexion et qui s'est nourri de
l'expérience de demande à voisins
bretons n'ont effectivement puisque
j'étais maire-adjoint en charge de la
sécurité de la voirie et des transports
et puis également conseiller
communautaire
alors vous me diriez pourquoi but en
cours alors parce que j'ai encore c'est
une ville à ville c'est une ville que
j'aime c'est une ville que je connais
depuis très très longtemps et c'est
également une ville où j ai de nombreux
amis
alors je suis un enfant de saint quentin
il faut savoir je connais guyancourt à
l'époque où guyancourt avait à peine
1500 habitants j'ai également été au
collège paul eluard et j'ai également
assisté
participer même à l'inauguration du
gymnase maurice baquet voilà donc
maintenant j'ai élu domicile
je vais voter aux européennes j'ai
également participé un bureau de vote
voilà concernant notre programme nous on
a une approche qui est plutôt
pragmatique qui est d'aller à la
rencontre des lions courtois et de là
est sorti un programme concernant mon
engagement donc je dis ce continent
quand on aurait pu sans pouvoir les
questions de toute agitation réfléchir à
cet engagement et je veux dire augure
encore toi que je vais pleinement me
consacrer à ma belle à des qte
candidature est portée par l'union des
démocrates musulmans français vous êtes
ingénieur en informatique également
président de l'association espoir et
soutient sans frontières pourquoi vous
présentez cette année on s'aperçoit
depuis quand même quelques années
maintenant et billancourt qui commençait
à avoir une relâche mans voir une des
collections dans certains domaines de la
part de l'équipe municipale vis-à-vis
des bilans courtois aussi gain d'un
point de vue associatif
j'en suis le témoin aujourd'hui en tant
que président d'une association puis
bientôt six ans une vie en cours et qui
malheureusement n'existe pas sur
guyancourt depuis le début on l'a je
m'excuse auprès de monsieur morton qui
n'était pas le maire à l'époque mais je
sais que à plusieurs reprises nous avons
eu des des petits soucis on va dire de
commander administratif avec la mairie
on n'a jamais pu être présent sur les
comment dire les annuaires en ligne des
associations sur sur le site internet de
la mairie on oublie je ne sais pas
pourquoi refuser on le refait
systématiquement des salles lorsqu'on
demande une pour justement faire des
collectes alimentaires et les
redistribuer ces desserreront demande
pour deux jours uniquement on lui dit
que voilà ça porterait préjudice aux
associations actuelle sur le terrain
alors que c'est complètement autre faut
être entonnés que nous mêmes nous
travaillons avec les associations donc
il ya vraiment une déconnexion on
al'impression entre l'équipe municipale
et ce qui se passe réellement sur le
terrain et nous sommes pas les seuls
association danse dans ce cas de figure
malheureusement il y en a d'autres et
d'où mon engagement aujourd'hui pour une
justice sociale équitable sur lui en
cours et aussi pour
pour arrêter ce clientélisme comme
interassociatif cinquième il est
également présente sur cuit en cours
grégory pape vous vous dites neuf en
politique premiers pas en politique
c'est en devenant animateurs du comité
local en marche à guyancourt s'était
tant c'était il ya tout juste un an
je suis un nouveau venu en politique
donc je vais commencer par une une brève
présentation au niveau professionnel je
suis pharmacien
je suis élu comme conseiller à l'ordre
des pharmaciens et j'ai créé une
association humanitaire qui est
l'antenne living de pharmacie
humanitaire internationale
donc je suis je me mets au service de
mes patients au service de mes confrères
au service des populations démunies est
désormais en me présentant comme maire
je me mettrai au service de la
population de guyancourt alors pour moi
c'est un challenge mais je suis
entrepreneur et j'aime le challenge
au niveau personnel j'ai trois enfants
qui ont tous qu'ils sont tous nés à
guyancourt et j'ai 41 noms suis le plus
jeune des candidats
j'ai de l'énergie à revendre et je vais
mettre cette énergie au service des
habitants de williencourt
alors on a commencé le travail de
terrain il ya un peu plus d'un an et le
constat est que que guyancourt est une
ville dortoir est une ville endormie et
pour cause tous les tous les six ans on
nous ressert le même programme
programme sans ambition au programme
juste réalisable alors que nous avec
notre équipe riche par sa diversité du
nouvel élan et guyancourt
nous nous souhaitons remettre remettre
dit encore m du dynamisme conduit en
cours
nous sommes conscients que guillon cours
un potentiel énorme et nous projetons
nous nous avons présenté un projet de
ville ambitieux donc ce zola cet après
midi je vais vous présenter quelques
éléments et nous allons présenter notre
programme complet le 26 février à 20
heures à la villa jean monnet merci à
tous les cinq pour ce premier tour de
table déjà pour cette première
présentation nous allons revenir sur
plusieurs thématiques nous allons
débuter par la démocratie locale
françois morton avec vous pour la
première course cette première réponse
44 secondes de temps de parole un petit
peu moins donc vous pouvez a débuté dans
parmi vos propositions concernant la
démocratie locale vous avez la mise en
place de conseils citoyens par exemple
dans les comptes dans l'est dans les
quartiers la création de dispositifs
aussi notamment du numérique pour
dialoguer avec le maire et l'équipe
municipale pour d'autres vos
propositions quels sont les moments le
plus important pour vous autant de sept
thèmes est alors d'abord quand même pour
pour refixer un petit peu les choses on
n'a pas attendu les six derniers mois
pour refaire de la démocratie locale
si je veux prendre quelques chiffres
ligne uniquement sur ce dernier mandat
ces derniers mandats c'est plus de 200
réunions publiques ses 80 permanence des
élus
c'est 60 allô monsieur le maire et je
pourrais citer les visites de quartier
les assemblées de quartier depuis que je
suis maire ne se passe pas un jour sans
que je rencontre d'aiguillon courtois
que ce soit dans des moments informels
ou plus formel effectivement au travers
de réunions
maintenant je sais que les pratiques les
pratiques changent la société change
c'est évident j'ai eu la chance durant
ce mandat de mettre en place le conseil
citoyen dans le cadre du contrat de
ville dans le quartier du pont du rotois
c'est une instance qui n'était pas
simple à mettre en place parce qu'elle
se devait d'être structuré et c'est une
instance qui fonctionne maintenant elle
est la seule d'ailleurs au sein de saint
quentin en yvelines a continué à
fonctionner puisque des représentants du
conseil citoyen viennent d'ailleurs
représenter le conseil citoyen du pont
du routard et donc de guyancourt dans
les instants saint-quentinoise donc
c'est effectivement le seul qui
continuent à fonctionner car il a été
bien structuré donc moi ce que je
souhaite est l'une des propositions que
nous faisons dans ce programme c'est de
le développer à l'échelle de l'ensemble
des quartiers mais d'aller aussi au delà
de ça c'est à dire avec des comités
d'usagers
par exemple dans les différentes écoles
de municipal l'école municipale de
musique de danse pourquoi pas de crèches
aussi et puis j'ai un projet ambitieux
vous savez que probablement que les
questions d'éducation sont très chers et
je souhaite effectivement créer un
nouvelle instance
un conseil local d'éducation à l'échelle
de la ville olivier paréja parmi vos
propositions concernant la démocratie
locale la création de commissions extra
municipales
tout à fait mais en fait on peut faire
des réunions où on peut réunir des
centaines de gens on peut faire des très
grandes salles
mais en fait la question est qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce qu'on y fait est ce qu'on
y présente un projet déjà complètement
ficelé et auquel cas on informe les gens
ou alors est ce qu'on construit les
projets à l'avance avec les habitants et
c'est ce que nous voulons proposer c'est
à dire que nous on est convaincu qu'il y
aura toujours plus d'intelligence avec
une dizaine une vingtaine une centaine
d'habitants que de trois personnes dans
un bureau
donc l'intérêt c'est de construire les
commissions qui sont aujourd'hui réservé
aux services techniques aux élus c'est
de les ouvrir aux habitants c'est la
porte ouverte c'est la transparence
peut-être qu'il ya deux cent mille
personnes qui vont venir mais simplement
ça sera possible de participer de
construire les projets de proposer des
projets et pas seulement d'attendre
d'avoir déjà le projet ficelé sur lequel
on peut éventuellement changer la
couleur d'un poteau et guère plus mme
amel a dit yu que je vous passe à
présent la parole et bien sûr je le
précise à tous les candidats n'hésitez
pas si vous souhaitez vous aussi
intervenir me faire un petit signe et je
vous passerai la parole oui si réagir
les uns par rapport aux propositions des
autres c'est aussi l'objectif de cette
émission m'a bel addy cube sur la
démocratie locale
avant tout il faut être je pense qu'il
faut être à l'écouté des habitants dans
une logique de collaboration de
partenariat il ne faut pas se sentir
être le seul concerné par l'action
locale à l'action publique locale
il faut vivre la démocratie au delà des
périodes électorales également
et justement faire en sorte de favoriser
cet engagement citoyen que chaque
personne devrait avoir en ville
maintenant il faut savoir aussi que on a
besoin d'eux de créer une certaine
dignité retint dynamisme une certaine
comment dire à un certain engagement une
certaine confiance avec ses habitants
justement pour pouvoir déployer des
actions sur le terrain qu'ils soient
comment tu iras cohérente avec la
politique de la ville il faut six à
travers cet engagement et cette
confiance justement prend pour
ajustement à attirer les habitants vers
un arrangement citoyens qu'ils soient
comment dire qu'ils soient participative
dans la ville et qui soit en même temps
comment dire pour pouvoir engager les
citoyens dans les questions où les
problématiques de leur ville au
quotidien tout simplement et grégory
pape je me tourne vers vous parmi vos
propositions ce qui sera peut-être aussi
réagir les autres candidats vous avez la
mise en place d'un comité d'évaluation à
mi mandat est en fin de mandat
oui j'ai un peu les actions qui ont été
menées alors ça c'est pour la
transparence
j'y reviendrai un peu plus tard là je
voudrais vraiment parler d'eux pour
l'instant la démocratie locale parce que
c'est là parce que c'est une réelle
attente des gayant courtois nous voyons
aux dernières élections municipales nous
avons frôlé la moitié d'abstentionnistes
la moitié c'est énorme
l'aiguillon courtois ne veulent plus que
leur voix porte seulement le jour des
élections ils veulent que leur voix
porte sur les six ans sur toute la durée
du monde donc nous allons tout faire
pour impliquer tous les habitants dans
les décisions de la ville
comment nous allons faire nous enfin
nous allons faire également des comités
de quartier mais avec un budget
participatif pour que les projets
puissent vraiment aboutir nous allons
créer des conseils des sages à
guyancourt nous avons la chance et nous
avons été précurseurs sur la création du
conseil municipal des enfants
c'est génial je suis vraiment super mais
ce conseil ne s'est pas des enfants
s'arrêtent en cinquième donc que sais je
sais que 12 ans j'ai pas mes enfants
encore à cet âge là mais j'ai pas aimé
donc nous souhaitons continuer prolonger
ce conseil ne s'est pas des enfants
conseil municipal de la jeunesse jusqu'à
nous allons vous parliez des
associations qui était pas forcément
écouté
nous allons créer un conseil de la vie
associative pour que les associations se
regroupent communique plus avec la
mairie et puissent mutualiser leurs
moyens
nous allons vraiment révolutionné le
mode de gouvernance j'en viens
maintenant à la transparence donc vous
parliez des du comité d'évaluation
effectivement les lieux en courant ont
pu le voir ces derniers temps là
l'équipe municipale en place programmée
pourrait proclamer pardon engagements
pris engagements tenus avec ce comité
d'évaluation avec des habitants tirent
au sort ce ne sera plus possible de
s'autoproclamer engagements pris en gage
non tenues sur les autres éléments de
transparence rapidement rapidement
nous transmettrons le maximum
d'événements de la ville en live sur
internet et enfin un autre un autre
point nous avons identifié c'est la
qualité des coûts de la mairie nous nous
inscrirons dans un référentiel
qualiville pour évaluer la qualité
d'écouté de l'équipe municipale françois
morton si vous souhaitez réagir
oui alors notamment sur cette histoire
des engagements pris engagements tenus
enfin si nous affirmons à l'heure
actuelle que les 100 % des engagements
pris en 2014 ont été tenus c'est
simplement parce que c'est la réalité
alors je veux dire qu'on puisse les
prises parvenu non mais enfin il ya un
programme en 2014 je vous propose
d'aller revoir si vous l'avez peut-être
chez vous et regardez et vous verrez que
les engagements qui ont été pris en 2014
ont été tenus en 2020 enfin voila c'est
factuel moi je veux bien qu'on puisse
épiloguer 116 sur cette affaire c'est
juste factuel voilà ce n'est qu'ensemble
ils vous ouvrent un parent est évaluée
par un comité qui ressort alors les
évaluations lors lors des municipales
sont intervalles réguliers alors d'abord
il ya tous les six ans d'accord dire
qu'à un moment donné les électeurs se
rendent aux urnes
et puis moi je vais vous dire quelque
chose la liste guyancourt pour tous à
publier tous les ans jusqu'à la mi
mandat
et encore une fois la limande à un
retour annuel sur l'ensemble des
réalisations
vous les avez probablement archives et
chez vous et si ça n'est pas le cas
écoutez je vous dis renvoi je passe la
parole à rodolphe baril à présent nous a
pas entendus sur ce sujet pour vous les
conseils de quartier ont un rôle
important à jouer
aussi on veut rapprocher vraiment le
quartier
de la mairie le conseil de quartier est
incontournable c'est quelque chose moi
j'ai vécu leur mes précédentes
expériences
il est clair que qui mieux que les
habitants du quartier peuvent parler de
leur quartier l'idée c'est de les
associer à en amont à tous les projets
de la famille et de la municipalité
on ne mettra nous toutes façons dédiera
à maire-adjoint aux conseils de quartier
à la démocratie locale et dans chaque
conseil de quartier on y mettra un élu
du quartier
alors je juste nous sont mortes en
parliez du conseil citoyen je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec vous c'est quelque
chose qui était mis en place ne fait pas
été une volonté politique de votre
municipalité puisque c'est une
élongation
c'est une obligation il avait eu cette
petite précision concernant la
transparence de nos décisions pareilles
on communiquera un bilan annuel
et puis on mettre en place à une
communication sur le suivi de nos
engagements une fois par an je voulais
vivre
rapidement d'autres d'autres idées aussi
l'extension du conseil municipal pour
enfants conseil municipal jeunes
jusqu'aux je suis enfant du lycée est ce
que je pense que c'est important
l'idée c'est également d'intégrer le
conseil municipal jeunes dans les
conseils de quartier
et puis l'utilisation des nouvelles
technologies pour communiquer avec une
retransmission des conseils municipaux
olivier pareil vous avez un peu de temps
de retard de parole si vous souhaitez
vous exprimer encore sur ce sujet si
nous songeons de thématiques avec la
face et locales les conseils de quartier
peuvent effectivement avoir un intérêt
mais on voit dans beaucoup de villes que
c'est aussi un dispositif qui suis un
petit peu en fait et notre proposition
serait plutôt de créer des des comités
d'action projet comme ça a été fait dans
certaines villes à l'occasion par
exemple d'un projet important sur le
marché par exemple la rénovation du
marché ou sur la rénovation du mail des
soldes il ya quelques années on aurait
pu créer un comité avec les habitants
qui du coup se mobilisent pendant
quelques années seulement parce que le
côté conseil de quartier avec un élu est
là et c'est ça peut aussi s'user un
petit peu donc il faut trouver des
nouvelles formes de
de renouveau pour arriver à faire
participer les gens et je reviendrai
aussi sur les associations où
effectivement il ya besoin d'inclure
plus les associations dans la vie
municipale en particulier notre
proposition tourne autour d'eux si ça
les intéresse de créer une maison des
associations mais en tous les cas
d'arrivée à redonner aux associations
plus de être plus partie prenante que
être une déclinaison d'un projet
municipal mais que vraiment ça soit elle
qui soit à la source des propositions il
pas vous souhaitiez réagit un seul
retrait si je vous avais beaucoup
d'avancé on parle donc très brièvement
maintenant juste pour dire que je
rejoins entièrement olivia paréja sur
cette idée de conseil créé pour pour
mener des grands projets sur la ville
françois marton oui non je voulais dire
j'entends j'entends effectivement j'ai
entendu parler de clientélisme qui est
un terme que je évidemment que je
rejette très fort tout à l'heure de la
part de monsieur de cure de cube et
effectivement il ya 130 associations sur
la ville de mieux en cours alors je
pense qu'il n'est pas très compliqué
d'en trouver une ou deux effectivement
qui peuvent avoir quelques griefs et je
le conçois absolument mais mais mais
mais ça c'est vous qui le dites monsieur
de plus qu'au vu de la corse exemple
écoutez vous les donnerais peut-être
vous aurez l'occasion de le faire mais
lente mais en tout cas ce que je veux
dire c'est globalement les associations
sur la ville de guyancourt félicite
plutôt la politique municipale
j'entendais parler d' usure tout à
l'heure de conseils de quartier de
projets meilleur moyen pour que ça ne
s'use pas 700 occupés et de l'animer
c'est le seul moyen
moi je voulais revenir sur la
transparence parce que la transparence
ce n'est pas seulement donner des infos
une fois par an et des choses de ce type
la transparence par exemple c'est sûr
les associations quelque chose que moi
je je réclame depuis plusieurs années au
conseil municipal c'est de savoir
quelles associations ont quelles
subventions quelles associations ont
quel
avantages en nature si peut être des
salsas peut être on n'arrive pas par
exemple à avoir le planning des salles
de guyancourt savoir celles qui sont
occupées celles qui ne sont pas occupés
et donc par exemple je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui l'agglomération de saint
quentin assure la partie associations
une déclinaison beaucoup plus
transparente où on voit telle
association a eu tant cette année avait
8 ans l'année dernière est sûre et
reçoit une subvention pour tel projet
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose et quand
on parle de transparence c'est pas
seulement transmettre son bilan c'est
aussi donner les informations pour que
les gens puissent comprendre ce qui se
passe dans la ville un dernier mot sur
ce sujet oui effectivement j'ai une
thématique jeux comment dire je continue
sur cette sur ce terme de clientélisme
effectivement il ya un clientélisme que
vous vouliez ou non sur lui en cours il
est là malheureusement il ya beaucoup
d'associations aujourd'hui comme la
nôtre en l'occurrence qui ne pouvons pas
exercer ou qui ne vous voit plus exercer
sur lui en cours il y en a d'autres qui
ont déménagé à trappes
il y en a d'autres qui ont déménagé à
buc donc vous pouvez pas dire que qu'ils
ne sachent que nous trois messages en
est à 10 par semaine qui veut
s'installer à guyancourt me suis
justement il faut les énormes
oui oui dans le panneau absolument c'est
parfait en tout cas s'arrêter là pour
cette thématique là si on n'aura pas le
temps non pas le temps de parler sur les
autres sujets mais bien évidemment on
n'est pas là pour présenter tous les
points de programme simplement pour que
les candidats puissent échanger sur sur
quelques-uns et on renvoie tous les
électeurs de votre commune avoue
différents sites internet et elle est
vraiment contre est aussi directement
pour avoir vos différentes propositions
passons à l'écologie l'environnement
c'est un point qui se retrouve aussi sur
l'intégralité de vos programmes et même
dans toutes les communes aujourd'hui il
ya cette urgence climatique notamment et
qui interpelle tous les électeurs toutes
les électrices et les maires veulent
aussi répondre de l'oeuf baril ont
débuté avec avec vous sur ces
thématiques écologie environnement
développement durable restauration
scolaire implication des jeunes aussi
voilà quelques mots clés pour votre
programme pour nous là
le développement durable c'est un enjeu
c'est un sujet qui concerne tous les
légumes en courtois et qui concerne leur
mort tout le monde au delà des partis
politiques donc nous notre approche est
plutôt en appelant une approche
pragmatique de faire une écologie
pragmatique et non une écologie
politique donc on a trois on a trois
grands axes on a déjà ce sera un sujet
qui sera complètement con transversale
on a on a prévu de nommer à
maire-adjoint spécifiquement dédié au
développement durable
le son objectif ce sera de regarder tous
les sujets qui seront passés tous les
projets municipaux voire s'y rend dans
le cadre d'un développement durable et
qu'est ce qu'on peut apporter à ces à
ses projets en lien avec le
développement durable
on a trois grands axes l'éducation parce
que l'instruction citoyenne éduquer les
jeunes les adolescents pour qu'ils
viennent des ambassadeurs du
développement durable on veut réduire
l'impact du co2 sur les activités
municipales lors on à la flotte
automobile qui peut être renouvelée avec
des véhicules proches du zéro émission
voir mutualisation de la flotte
automobile en fonction de leur taux
d'utilisation la mise en place aussi
transport alternatif pour les employés
municipaux
et puis le regroupement de certains
bâtiments dans un seul nouveau bâtiment
qui serait en haute qualité énergétique
a minima en ce qui concerne
l'alimentation c'est un sujet qui est
aujourd'hui est traitée par la
municipalité avec un repas bio une fois
par semaine
nous ce qu'on veut c'est étendre ses
repas sur toute la surtout les jours de
la semaine avec des produits labellisés
blot et bio pardon et qui viendrait qui
vient pas d'eux qu'ils seraient issus
des circuits courts
alors on a aussi un gros projet qui
serait de garder la maîtrise complète et
totale de la chaîne de distribution pour
pour tous qu'alimentation voilà en gros
les les grandes lignes de ce sujet là
olivier parisien vous dites cette
mandature c'est celle de l'urgence
climatique
exactement et en fait
sur notre collectif sur notre liste nous
avons de nombreuses personnes qui
s'impliquent à guyancourt
depuis des années sur l'écologie c'est
pas des gens qui ont découvert l'urgence
écologique à l'occasion des élections ou
être dans une politique de développement
durable
un petit peu un petit peu limité on a
des gens qui ont créé des amap
on a des gens qui ont créé des ateliers
vélo on a des gens qui travaillent sur
la rénovation énergétique
donc en fait on apporte dans cette dans
cette mandature la volonté de vraiment
faire quelque chose parce que on a plus
10 en vingt ans pour faire quelque chose
et les collectivités locales sont à
l'initiative de une énorme part entre le
logement par exemple logement
typiquement c'est quelque chose quand on
fait de la rénovation
c'est bon pour la planète c'est bon pour
la facture des gens quand on fait de la
relocalisation de l'alimentation on peut
créer des fermes pas très loin urbaine
sur sur des friches ou sur des terrains
de la minière par exemple à guyancourt
ça crée de l'emploi ça permet
d'alimenter les cantines il ya tout un
cercle vertueux et l'écologie ne peut
pas se limiter à quelques mesures un
petit peu standard un petit peu connu
par tout le monde quoi médiatique je
voyais plutôt d'accord avec ce qui ce
qui était dit et si je reprends emprunt
de programmes aussi vous parler de cette
consommation pour réduire l'empreinte
carbone la gratuité dans les cantines
maternelle aussi pour les produits frais
bio et producteurs locaux lan c'est très
bien mais il faut le financer aussi donc
expliqué noah qui prévoit là bas
justement il faut le financer mais bon
en la partie bustier on s'y intéresse
actuellement à fait partie du programme
que nous avons au cours actuel pour
l'instant mais je rejoins tout à fait
monsieur barry monsieur parent et
j'assure sur ces problématiques ou cette
problématique nous avons à guyancourt
des associations qui sont je dirais même
expect experte pas redondant dans ce
genre de
deux domaines et je trouve triste on va
dire que qu'à la mairie on puisse pas
les intégrer totalement et fait en sorte
justement qu'elles puissent apporter
leur expertise pour faire évoluer les
choses au niveau au niveau municipal
nous avons quelques points qu'on voulait
développer également avec au sein de la
mairie c'était soutenir les initiatives
en faveur des colonies sur les
territoires faire passer les véhicules
de fonction à de la mairie à des
véhicules plus propres plus électrique
éventuellement on a la chance
aujourd'hui d'être d'avoir renault à
côté de chez nous chez nous on va dire
ce serait bien que par exemple
guyancourt devienne une ville pilote
dans ce domaine c'est triste d'avoir
renault et ne pas pouvoir en profiter
dans ce domaine a installé par exemple
des purificateurs d'air près des
échangeurs comme prochainement qui des
travaux vont commencer au rond-point des
sangliers
il faudrait installer des purificateurs
d'air je dirai au niveau des écoles et
des crèches aux environs faire en sorte
qu si on puisse consulter là les
riverains chose qu'on m'a dit vous
n'avez pas été consultés
concernant ce que cela va générer en
termes de pollution en termes de
nuisances sonores
il ya voudrait équipés par exemple les
bâtiments administratifs de panneaux
photovoltaïques voltaïque
et bien tu es bien d'autres choses
installé par exemple des contenants bio
compostables dans certaines structures
ce soit dans des cantines
que ce soit dans sur les places des
marchés etc quelle grippe a à présent on
vous écoute sur ses propositions pour
écologie environnement
oui ça se retrouve pas vous avez
beaucoup aussi de propositions qui sont
plus ou moins comme une prison est
d'accord sur tout ça conscient qu'il ya
une urgence urgence écologique que ce le
prochain mandat sera le mandat de la
transition écologique
nous devons prendre un virage sur ce sur
ce niveau là
c'est un combat que je mènerai pour mes
enfants pour les enfants de lui en cours
pour les enfants de la planète
quel cadre de vie allons-nous leur
laissez nous devons éduquer et
sensibiliser
il ya un sujet qui me tient à coeur
c'est le gaspillage alimentaire dans les
restaurations collectives
on nous allons évaluer ce gaspillage et
le diminuer à titre personnel j'ai
participé au défi zéro déchets organisée
par la lèque avec ma famille la lègue
fait un formidable travail sur le
terrain de saint quentin divine faisant
la promotion ils n'attendent que ça ils
font un super travail sur monsieur dés
que vous parlez tout à l'air de la
problème de salle de collecte
alimentaire
c'est dans l'introduction nous allons
proposer une ressourcerie cette
ressourcerie pourra accueillir des
collectes alimentaires aura une vocation
sociale et solidaire et ce sera un lieu
de vie pour tous les deux encourent
thouars un lieu d échange sur le réduit
en cours si une ville un peu
particulière nous avons de la chance
d'avoir des formidables atouts
environnementaux des étangs des forêts
je suis moi même venu habiter à
guyancourt pour les étangs d'aminé je
suis tombé en amour pour les étangs la
minière nous allons préserver tous ces
espaces plus aucune construction sur ces
espaces juste un mot sur le futur
quartier le quartier des savoirs ce sera
évidemment ce sera évidemment un
écoquartier enfin enfin je souhaite que
tous les projets soient évalués non
seulement termes financiers mais en
termes d'impact écologique est ce que je
veux oui pour finir pour finir c'est
qu'il faudra toujours évaluer cet impact
écologique elle nous allons mettre en
place des des indicateurs par exemple
lorsque les travaux sur la ville et
qu'il ya des arbres arrachés il faudra
qu'il soit systématiquement remplacé si
on peut afficher les temps de parole des
uns et des autres olivier paréja vous
souhaitez réagir et ensuite ce sera à
force françois morton te parler de cette
question
moi je suis juste un petit peu gêné par
toutes ces déclarations
qui sont à leur enthousiasme et pour
l'environnement mais quand même
concrètement le gouvernement donc les
amis de monsieur pape dans les deux
derniers jours sont revenus en arrière
sur les objectifs de co2 de la france
en décalant à la mandature suivante le
fait de les baisser sur le glyphosate
les amis de monsieur barry à la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin ne met aucun moyen pour le pour
le développement du plan climat
enfin il ya un écart entre les discours
qui sont enthousiasmants et la réalité
il faut quand même assumé monsieur barry
pour réagir oui mais vous les posez la
question à monsieur monsieur paré
jacquier qui est élu depuis très
longtemps et qui représente écologie les
verts moi je suis un peu surpris je suis
de l'avis de grégory pape sur
l'écoquartier pour moi tous les nouveaux
quartiers doivent être sous forme d'éco
quartier jouaient juste qu'il nous fasse
le bilan de ce que lui l'a fait pendant
ces années de mandature en tant qu
écologie les verts il n'y a même pas un
écoquartier à guyancourt
elle a même pas un bon on va pas tourner
le débat là contre l'autre en impôts en
un mot par mario bernard gaud en un mot
je n'ai jamais été en position de
décider
j'étais dans l'opposition et donc au
départ oui et je suis sorti et j'en suis
sorti parce que je n'arrivais justement
pas à faire bouger les choses à la fois
sur la démocratie participative est à la
fois sur l'écologie et je vous arrête là
écoutons monsieur morton à présent voilà
j'avais comme je suis aussi rappelé
quelques quelques vérités c'est à dire
qu'on a l'impression que la transition
écologique sur la ville de guyancourt et
la trois semaines enfin je veux dire à
un moment donné reprenons les faits
guyancourt a été une ville précurseur
notamment au niveau des produits
phytosanitaires par exemple puisqu'elle
a devancé la loi on peut faire la moue
mais c'est une réalité
nous avons étendu les jardins familiaux
récemment nous mettons en place très
bientôt monsieur de cube le premier
composteur collectif sur la voie
publique de saint quentin en yvelines
voilà non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que vous pouvez vous avez aussi le droit
de dire mon programme c'est écrit des
dents voilà donc ce sont des choses vous
pouvez
lutter contre le gaspillage c'est des
choses qui sont faites au quotidien avec
nos accueils de périscolaire monsieur
pape
donc effectivement moi j'aime beaucoup
ce catalogue d'actions qui arrive en
période électorale mais la plupart des
actions et encore une fois j'y souscris
j'ai aucun problème avec ça d'accord la
plupart des actions que vous nous
décrivez sont déjà les en place donc bon
voilà c'est une chose le nouveau
quartier parlons-en
oui en fait effectivement parlons-en je
pense que c'est un manque d'ambition que
de le qualifier d'écoquartier voilà je
vais être très clair avec vous c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné ce nouveau
quartier doit pas simplement être un éco
quartier parce que cette terminologie
pour moi elle est dépassée
voilà je vais très clair avec vous elle
est totalement dépassé elle veut tout
dire et rien dire
c'est un quartier qui doit être
totalement exemplaire mais pas
simplement à l'échelle de saint quentin
en yvelines ou de la région ile de
france
moi je souhaite que ce quartier il soit
exemplaire à l'échelle de la france
voilà ça c'est voilà c'est une ambition
une vraie ambition c'est à dire pas
simplement un éco quartier mais un
quartier à énergie positive par exemple
voilà qui privilégie effectivement
d'autres moyens de transport que la
voiture ce que je rappelle quand même
que c'est le quartier de la gare qu'il
aura à minima 12 lignes de bus
effectivement au moins pour l'instant on
en est pas encore là et qui sera un
quartier d équilibre et qu'il sera
effectivement travaillé dans son
aménagement avec l'ensemble de la
population de guyancourt et ce ne sera
pas un quartier exemplaire pour
quelques-uns ce sera un quartier
exemplaire pour tous ses habitants bien
entendu pour tous ses usagers bien
entendu mais aussi pour l'ensemble des
habitants de guyancourt voilà donc je
veux qu'on soit un tout petit peu plus
ambitieux que ça monsieur martin mathieu
des tubes en quelques secondes
oui je suis d'accord avec ça le fait que
ce soit un éco quartier ou même au tad à
l'éco quartier
mais que va-t-il advenir des autres
quartiers va-t-on travailler sur ces
quartiers là justement pour les mettre
on va dire au même niveau que ceux ses
prochains bien ce projet un quartier
jusqu'à présent on n'a pas eu de
nouvelles de ce côté là c'est toujours
vraiment tout à la dernière minute qu'on
va nous dire ah bah tout compte fait on
va faire sauver ses 6 mais bon cela ça
serait un peu plus tard ou bien au
prochain mandat
mais c'est pas comme ça que ça logis
parisien donc c'est très bien de dire
que je suis je rejoins ce que vous dites
en fait c'est la dernière minute en fait
les lits faut par exemple c'est une
injonction de la loi baissé de - 40 % la
facture énergétique de la ville et il
serait important d'avoir une
planification jusqu'en 2030 pour voir
comment nous allons atteindre cet
objectif et cet objectif ne sera ne sera
pas que dans le nouveau quartier
donc en fait on a déjà rénové une école
il falloir en rénover d'autres et du
coup il faudrait que cette trajectoire
soit connu et qu'on puisse ne pas
découvrir les projets aux familles
passent à innover une autre thématique
juste heureux dolphin paris vous avez un
peu plus de retard 4 minutes 52 les
autres sont à peu près à 6 minutes sauf
grégory patat cinq minutes 15
si vous souhaitez réagir sur ce sujet si
nous ne soit autre chose oui toujours
pour rebondir sur ce que disait monsieur
monsieur paréja le la mise en place ou
monsieur morton la mise en place de tout
ce qui est composteur c'est pas la ville
qui l'a qui a eu l'initiative c'est la
communauté d'agglomération qui a déployé
cette initiative là après que monsieur
par exemple monsieur morton veulent
développer il ya le souci est juste une
sonnerie parce que monsieur par les gens
parler de national mais moi je suis venu
pour vous parler du local évidemment
mais au niveau national le gouvernement
a lancé la convention citoyenne pour le
climat qui étais tu étais une initiative
complètement de nouvelle grippe a sont
la prochaine thématique sociale
solidarité place à la jeunesse pour vous
notamment sur le saut sur scène un petit
peu la transition est dure mais c'est
qu'on est un petit peu de temps pour
tout d'abord avec dix ans
si on est sociale et la solidarité à
guyancourt un des marqueurs forts de
guyancourt et le pourcentage de local de
logement locatif social qui est environ
à 50 % le parcours résidentiel est
important est un élément à travailler et
à guyancourt
ce parcours résidentiel s'arrête à la
location locatif social
non il faut aider les gens à devenir
propriétaires de leur logement
donc nous allons proposer un des
logements à l'accession aidée
enfin l'accession à la aidée à la
propriété ça c'est important il faut
continuer sur parcours résidentiel sur
un autre sujet le lien générationnel
enfin le lien social intergénérationnel
à guyancourt une super idée c'est la
résidence intergénérationnelle
ça c'est super mais ça touche que que
très peu de personnes au final donc il
faut vraiment multiplier multiplier ce
genre d'initiative la recyclerie la
ressourcerie en fera partie pour que ça
deviendra un lieu de rencontres inter
générationnelles sur le sur 50 ans
divine nous avons la chance d'avoir le
domaine du maire en tête qui est
précurseur sur le domaine de la perte
d'autonomie
appuyons nous sur eux faisons encore une
fois à faut en faire la promotion nous
avons des super outil sur saint quentin
en yvelines
jarno sujet qui me tient à coeur c'est
la restauration collective toujours non
seulement sur le problème du gaspillage
mais en préparant ce débat j'ai étudié
un peu les tarifs de toutes les villes
avoisinantes guyancourt et la plus chère
guyancourt et la plus chère du quotient
familial le plus bas jusqu'au plus haut
est-ce que guillon cours est une vraie
vie sociale je me demande si je suis élu
j'aimerais qu'on mette en place que plan
national pauvreté avec le repas à 1 euro
pour les plus démunis et enfin bon je
peux pas parler de solidarité sans
parler d'un sujet qui nous oppose
aujourd'hui avec le maire sortant
c'est le service minimum d'accueil en
cas de grève des enseignants dans les
écoles primaires
donc nous sommes complètement opposées
sur ce sujet monsieur morton défend
l'homme
le fait de ne pas le mettre en place
parce que ça à réduire l
je connais j'ai vu votre terme exact
mais ça va réduire l impact du droit de
grève et et 48 heures en qu'est le
préavis des enseignants vous paraît trop
juste pour mettre en place les actions
donc déjà je suis pour le point de grève
évidemment et je regarde encore une fois
les autres communes comme trappe qui l'a
mis en place même un village comme tous
indom mille habitants le mail en place
pourquoi hugo 29 mille habitants de peur
de mettre en place
françois martin vous voulez réussir si
vous le souhaitez vous pouvez répondre
sinon j'ai déjà longuement répondu aux
deux associations de parents d'élèves
qui ont émis l'appel à manifester sans
avoir demandé un rendez-vous merde
auparavant je tiens quand même la dir
est effectivement vous étiez présent
monsieur pas et c'est ainsi que vous
monsieur vous avez parfaitement droit
vous faisiez effectivement partie des 25
par an devant la mairie ce samedi matin
là effectivement et je réitère les
proprios aucun problème c'est une
atteinte au droit de grève et je
confirme
et ça n'est pas d'après moi monsieur
pape que ce délai de 48 heures ne permet
pas effectivement de s'assurer de la
bonne mise en place éventuelle de ce
service minimum d'accueil
c'est juste encore une fois factuel et
si des villes l'ont mis en place c'est
leur responsabilité et je ne juge
absolument pas cv nous apprenons que je
vais juste terminer ma phrase si vous le
permettez d'accord c'est juste de dire
que certaines villes longue vous citiez
trappe je crois d'accord avec un certain
nombre de places effectivement limités
si vous avez 50 places et que vous êtes
le 51e vous ne pouvez pas avoir votre
place
ça s'appelle un traitement inégalitaire
effectivement des usagers c'est parfois
sinon c'est juste interdit par la loi
monsieur pas messieurs voilà pour votre
pour votre réponse équilibrée petit peu
monsieur s'il vous plaît que tout le
monde puisse s'exprimer et que chacun
soit plus ou moins à égalité à la fin de
ce temps cette émission sur le temps de
parole doivent se marrer justement c'est
à vous vous avez largement le temps de
vous exprimer sur cette question du
social et de la solidarité si vous êtes
élu au sein de cette commune de guillon
devant moi j'ai rendre à la municipalité
actuelle
d'avoir d'un bon nombre de dispositifs
et de d'accompagnement dette sociale
déjà mis en place à guyancourt
donc ce sont des dispositifs que nous
conserverons et nous renforcerons si
elle nécessite évidemment de de les
renforcer
on va mettre en place quelque chose qui
n'existe pas à guyancourt a qui est
obligatoire pour les villes de plus de
50 mille habitants c'est le conseil des
droits et devoirs de la famille c'est un
dispositif d' aide à la parentalité qui
est fondée sur l'action sociale et
éducative
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on mettra en
place parce que ça ça fait ses preuves
dans d'autres communes on veut aussi
aider les parents et les familles
monoparentales en recherche d'emploi a
bénéficié de berceaux dédié en les
labellisant en labellisant des places de
crèche à vocation insertion
professionnelle alors évidemment on veut
renforcer l'aide aux devoirs on veut
renforcer le nombre d'éducateurs
spécialisés
notre souci sera d'assurer de façon
l'accompagnement continue des permanents
des familles et jeunes 10 ans courtois
jusqu'à leur majorité
on veut développer l'instruction
citoyenne j'en parlais tout à l'heure
avec le développement durable pour que
nos adolescents deviennent des
ambassadeurs du respect de
l'environnement
et puis également aider les personnes en
situation de handicap en développant un
service spécifique
et puis il ya une idée aussi que qu'on
veut mettre en place et dès que les
délocaliser régulièrement certains
services de la mairie dans l'est dans
les maisons de quartier
le sol est quand même assez loin de la
mairie las vegas est un service que l'on
peut délocaliser une fois par semaine
une fois par quinzaine une fois par mois
ce sera à définir
à palaja donc effectivement il ya un
souci sur le parcours de logements des
guyancourt toi et on focalise beaucoup
sur le logement social mais quand on
regarde le nombre de demandes de
logements sociaux qui existent sur la
ville
quand on regarde le pourcentage de ces
demandes presque deux tiers qui sont
issus de guyancourt toi compte
construire du logement social à
guyancourt
c'est quelque chose qui répond à des
demandes d guyancourt toi donc c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il faut il faut
il faut bien sûr répondre aux demandes
locales sur le logement et sur le
le prix du logement il ya peut-être des
choses qu'il faut aller chercher comme
aujourd'hui il ya des villes qui mettent
en place des offices foncier solidaire
qui permet de déconnecter le la
propriété du bâti de la propriété de et
qui du coup font baisser les tarifs donc
de 20 30 40 pour cent dans certaines
villes en particulier à lille dans le
nord
donc ça c'est des dispositifs comme les
dispositifs d'entreprises à but d'emploi
ou des choses comme ça qu'il faut aller
qu'il faut réfléchir qu'il faut essayer
de mettre en place ici
il ya des villes qui le font ça c'est
quelque chose que nous nous avons
beaucoup fait c'est d'essayer de trouver
des villes qui mettait déjà en oeuvre
les propositions qu'on fait dans notre
programme de façon à ne pas proposer des
choses dit réalisme et des choses qui
ont déjà été mises en place rodolphe
baril oui juste et y réagir ouais juste
une précision par rapport à ce que dit
monsieur parisien quand il dit que les
logements la construction de logements
sociaux c'est une demande des duos
courtois dans c'est une volonté
politique c'est pas une demande légumes
pour toi c'est une volonté politique la
loi sru elle prévoit 25 % de logements
sociaux à partir du moment où on en met
25 % répondent à l'offre avons rejoint
la demande parmi à peu près 2000 le
demande de logements sociaux à un
instant t sur wii en cours et il y en a
60 % qui sont des clients courtois c'est
bien une demande de guyancourt toi dans
celle ci
c'était un besoin mais il ya des coups
d'éclat pardon vous écoute à présent
aucun logement c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit depuis quelques années
quand même que ça poussent comme des
champignons
guyancourt il ya énormément de logements
malheureusement canton
commencent à s'intéresser aulas tout ce
qui est logement social sur la ville
comme disait monsieur pareil cas il ya
une très grande demande de logement
social à guyancourt et elle n'est pas
pour vous elle ne peut pas être pourvu
et très souvent on refuse parce qu'à
cause des du montant de loyer qui est
trop élevé quand vous quittez un
appartement où vous avez l'habitude de
payer 400 500 600 euros et qu'on vous
propose à nouveau un nouvel appartement
qui va vous coûter le double la vourasie
réfléchissez à deux fois et vous dit pas
tout compte fait ça sera pas pour moi je
passe mon tour donc c'est vrai que de ce
côté là il faudrait peut-être travailler
un peu plus avec les bailleurs sociaux
et de revoir ce qui peut être fait dans
ce domaine les guyancourt toile même les
pluies des les plus défavorisés entre
guillemets ne vont pas forcément vouloir
toujours avoir avoir à demander aux
aides des aides sociales pour pouvoir
s'en sortir
les gens veulent sortir la tête de terre
et de se dire voilà je peux me
débrouiller tout seul maintenant
maintenant en termes de pour les jeunes
je trouve quand on a la chance à
guyancourt d'avoir énormément de
structures sportives
donc de ce côté là c'est très bien c'est
très bien de septembre à juin
arrivé en juillet août ces structures
pour la plupart sont fermés les clubs
sont fermés donc on a une jeunesse qui
se trouve à guyancourt surtout les ados
lation les adolescents pardon ce qui
entraîne entre 13 14 ans jusqu'à aller
19 20 ans se retrouve à ne rien faire
sur guyancourt et c'est triste on n'aura
pas de structure pour les accueillir
très souvent j'entends des personnes qui
me disent oui mais il ya les terrains de
foot et peuvent jouer au foot oui mais
quand on est une fille on n'a pas
vraiment envie de jouer au foot
donc il faut comprendre aussi que
guillon cours pour les jeunes qui va
laisser passer ça
le foot il ya je vais dire le
pourcentage de garçons est quand même
assez élevé par rapport au nombre des
filles qu'on pouvait comprendre oui il
faut comprendre par donc que depuis en
cours aujourd'hui est la quatrième ville
la plus chère pour les étudiants et ça
c'est un rapport qui date de août 2019
de l'unef qui classe clients couvrant
quatrième position et je pense qu'il ya
énormément à faire pour des étudiants
qui paye 670 euros
un logement je vous arrête au musée d
histoire de conclure en fait c'est à peu
près à 8 minutes sauf monsieur barry et
monsieur morton qu'on n'a pas encore
entendu sur le sujet donc j'aimerais
qu'on écoute émotions morton à présent
et on doit le baril ensuite après
viendra le temps des conclusions
monsieur pas que je sais que vous
souhaitez la parole vous êtes largement
en avance ce sera pas possible sinon
nous n'ont pas dégagé t on donc je veux
faire court sur les solidarités c'est un
peu dommage enfin donc je suis sûr de
retard d'accord ok sur le logement or je
rejoins totalement rivier c'est un réel
besoin et effectivement je rappelle
quand même que 60 près de 70% de la
population francilienne est éligible au
logement social
alors je veux bien qu'on fasse un déni
absolu de cette question du logement
mais c'est juste encore une fois une
réalité
voilà ça n'est pas un fantasme ce sont
des chiffres et c'est factuel
voilà la ville de guyancourt à l'heure
actuelle comporte à peu près 48 % de
logements sociaux
nous allons continuer évidemment
construire durant le mandat il a été
construit davantage monsieur pape
d'accession à la propriété que de
logement social vous pouvez faire
dodeliner de la tête une salle bien
voilà non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que vous nous dites il faudrait faire
oui il ya qu'à eh bien écoutez c'est
fait l'accession aidée vous connaissez
probablement probablement l'implantation
du programme ariane et cassiopée
oui j'imagine que vous le situer
parfaitement d'accord c'est 100% j'ai vu
d'accès serait bien effectivement aider
donc encore une fois je vous remercie
pour vos conseils mais ce sont des
choses qui sont faites
encore une fois c'est en seconde dans le
cadre de alors je voudrais juste dans la
question des solidarités aborder la
question de la santé
on en a pas parlé je rappelle que la
ville de guyancourt a eu la
labellisation parlant
nisation mondiale de la santé c'est une
vraie question un vrai enjeu la santé
pour la ville de nuit en cours on va
être confronté à des départs de médecins
et sachez que la ville de guyancourt et
en tout cas c'est mon souhait travail
pour que non seulement les médecins
restent implantée à guyancourt
mais que davantage de médecins viennent
s'y implanter rodolphe baril oui je suis
au delà des pour rebondir sur les
logements sociaux au delà de la
réflexion qui sera menée sur les
prochains programmes
il ya quand même une urgence aujourd'hui
c'est de mettre là la pression auprès
des bailleurs sociaux faut réhabiliter
certains se logements sociaux qui
existent aujourd'hui que j'ai pu visiter
et qui sont vraiment dans un état
déplorable
vous semblez plutôt d'accord les visites
je rencontre les bailleurs et je
rencontre les habitants aussi nous
allons passer aux conclusions nous
aurons pas le temps d'aborder la
dernière thématique nous avions prévu la
sécurité si vous souhaitez en parler au
cours de vos conclusions conclusion qui
rend des temps très variable afin
d'équilibrer un peu à la parole de
chacun je précise tout de même que la
campagne se poursuit jusqu'à la veille
du premier tour ce sera le 15 mars
donner la parole d'ici là bien
évidemment nous allons débuter avec vous
olivier paréja pour la conclusion c'est
l'ordre inverse de tout à l'heure alors
excusez-moi dans l'autre sens avec le
gorille pas qu'on va commencer
voyez j'ai pas dit les bons numéros
foutant merci d'avoir veillé à lille
reste combien de temps pour votre
conclusion grégory pas vous aurez une
minute à peu près d'accord donc je
prends juste quelques secondes parce que
j'ai pas le temps de terminer ça retombe
parole oui avec monsieur neuf missions
sur ces harris minimale d'accueil qui
est une loi et ça m'étonne de voir un
maire qui se targue de ne pas respecter
la loi et de laisser les parents dans la
galère les jours de grève je conclus je
conclus
je conclus ces élections seront
également l'occasion enfin on nous
allons également voté pour nos
représentants à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc cette
importance et des expos qui compte
double et j'en appelle à tous les
guillaume courtois qui aiment leur ville
tous les deux ans courtois qui
souhaitent un maire qui soient à leur
écoute
un maire qui les implique dans les
décisions de leur ville un mec un maire
qui les représentent dignement
un maire qui souhaite faire réussir vie
en cours mobilisez-vous les 15 et 22
mars afin de faire réussir qui vit en
cours je souhaite juste dire un mot
merci à vous tous mes concurrents du
jour l'élection section est une
compétition
ont décidé guyancourt quoi mener durant
courtois me font confiance et que je
suis élu maire je vous tendrait la main
pour qu'on travaille ensemble afin de
faire réussir puis en cours babel a dit
que pour votre conclusion vous avez une
minute trente sur l'aspect sécurité
ensuite je conclurai si ça me dérange
pas c'est vrai qu'en à guyancourt en
termes de sécurité
il ya encore quelques quelques domaines
à comment dire à développer à savoir
comment dire un peu plus de moyens pour
la police municipale
certes peut-être plus de
vidéosurveillance certes également mais
il faudrait aussi se pencher sur le sur
7 sur ces jeunes qui souvent sont mis de
côté ceci dit ceci dit ah voilà je me
présente à guyancourt aujourd'hui je ma
liste n'est pas encore complète
j'appelle tous les livres courtoise et
cuits en courtois à vouloir s'investir
avec nous s'ils le désirent nous sommes
ouverts à toutes et à tous sans
distinction de religion de confection ou
de condition sociale
donc gros show new si vous voulez et
partageant et je vous arrête là pour
passer à présent je vérifier sur l'étang
hordorf baril et c'est à vous vous avez
une minute trente pour conclure entre un
mini car la tranquillité publique pour
nous il ya trois axes la prévention le
développement d'un véritable réseau de
vidéoprotection et le renforcement des
effectifs de pnb donc de police
municipale pour permettre une amplitude
horaire est d'être présent 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 sur la commune
concernant ma conclusion nous nous avons
construit un programme de 80 engagements
on parle pas de proposition on parle
d'engagement on a une majorité actuelle
qui est installée sans partage depuis 37
ans avec un troisième maire sur ce saut
ce mandat nous nous proposons de donner
un nouveau souffle à guyancourt
et si les gluants courtois tous les
goûts encore toi qui va contribuer à se
donner ce nouveau souffle jean propose
de voter dès le premier tour dès le 15
mars pour notre liste ensemble agissons
pour but en cours vous avez encore peu
près une minute si vous souhaitez
l'utiliser sinon voilà vous avez fait le
tour très bien passons à françois morton
à présent vous avez 40 secondes pour
conclure oui alors 40 secondes j'aurais
souhaité parler d'éducation aussi
évidemment la tranquillité publique est
une question que je n'ai jamais éludé
les moyens de la police municipale ne
doivent en aucun cas faire oublier que
la tranquillité publique et la sécurité
est une fonction régalienne de l'état et
je pense que la responsabilité d'un
maire c'est de soutenir la police
nationale aussi voilà ça c'était la
première des choses
la dernière chose que je souhaiterais
dire car j'ai très peu de temps si j'ai
bien compris que c'est comme ça c'est de
dire que je vais mener une liste de
gauche avec des valeurs parce qu'on n'a
pas beaucoup parlé de valeurs
aujourd'hui
donc moi je tiens les réaffirmé je pense
que ça n'est pas obsolète que de parler
de valeurs de gauche
surtout lorsque on est face à des
opposants qui met beaucoup d'énergie à
cacher leur étiquette en appelant
effectivement leur liste sans étiquette
alors qu'il se partage l'ensemble des
labels de la droite top noir était là
c'est à vous relie les parisiens pour
conclure une minute trente à peu près
voilà très bien et manou en fait on ne
rentre pas dans cette
dans ce cadre de dire on a des
engagements on a des propositions en
valais on va les tenir
nous c'est plutôt de proposer le cadre
de on a bien sûr des orientations
on a bien sûr des valeurs on l'affiché
dès le début trois valeurs qui sont la
participation démocratique la démocratie
là l'écologie est une composante sociale
solidarité c'est des valeurs de base que
qu'on a affiché depuis le début et qu'on
maintient mais ce que nous on voudrait
c'est plutôt mettre en place un cadre de
façon à ce que les habitants les
habitantes puisse reprendre en main les
décisions de la commune et qu'on arrive
vraiment à cheminer ensemble pour
arriver à mettre en place des choses qui
sont importantes pour la transition
écologique par exemple pour l'urgence
sociale également par ailleurs de tous
les porte à porte qu'on fait très
régulièrement nous montre que les gens
sont en demande de ces sujets là ça
rejoint ce qu'on a vu au niveau plus
plus globale sur les gilet jaune l'année
dernière sur la participation grand
débat les gens sont ont envie de
s'impliquer dans la vie citoyenne et
c'est ce que nous voulons proposer pour
arriver à avancer plus sur l'écologie
avant si plus sur le social les temps de
parole vous avez tous passé les neuf
minutes sauf un peu de retard pour dolce
barry comme je l'avais indiqué merci à
tous les 5 et d'avoir participé à ce
elle débat d'avoir sombré cette
thématique et débat que vous retrouverez
prochainement sur notre site internet
à suivre également sur radio sensations
et à très bientôt sur tv 78 pour un
nouveau débat du premier tour sur les
principales communes des yvelines
[Musique]